hi welcome to a new episode of project
camp
in this video we have a cool surprise
for you guys and we will introduce you
to a nice member of our crew
and at the end we will have an interview
with our neighbor tonakish
so i hope you enjoy this episode
but first i would like to show you a bit
more of our daily life here on project
camp
so since the work days here can be quite
intense and challenging it is important
to keep people's minds and body happy
and healthy and one of the main keys to
do that is to have a good food
in the first year we cooked everything
by ourselves which was more or less okay
since we were a small group of people
now in season 2 we are a bit different
more people more work less time for us
to prepare food so we have now the
luxury to have a person who takes care
of that and provides us with a beautiful
and delicious vegan food
yes we went for a vegan chef
and hot topic we are aware of that
uh some of you will argue that we should
eat vegan some of you will argue that we
should eat animal local products the
truth is that we don't really know what
is the best approach
and for now we just stand somewhere in
the middle
for instance sometimes we get
eggs from our neighbors and if we would
be very strict we would throw them away
or we would not accept them and that's
also not cool
and when we are vegan it's also very
easy to end up with very exotic
industrialized food like
vegan burgers or coconut water and
that's a lot of package and a lot of
traveling for a product and we don't
think that's any better
so for season two we decide to go fully
vegan during the week and during
weekends we are a bit more open for
different interpretations
the truth is that we are all different
and different paths in life and
different choices so we just trust that
everyone decides what's better for them
and what's better for the planet but if
you have any suggestions for season
three just let us know and we might
adapt and now that we are 71.4
vegan uh let me just introduce you to
the new project chef
i'm still blurry right nope
hello i'm agnes but everyone calls me
aggie i'm 30 years old and originally
coming from a small village called night
seikei in hungary but living now in
budapest i do a variety of stuff like
dancing writing scripts for tv shows
illustration and i'm also very
passionate with food and cooking since a
month now i'm the chef here in project
camp i usually prepare lunch and dinner
on workdays for the whole group on
fridays it's only lunch because we have
there the pizza night on weekends we
normally improvise whoever feels hungry
start to cook for everyone
of course it is a challenge to prepare
food here in a more or less improvised
kitchen with a reduced variety of
supplies but i'm quite used to it since
i cook often for groups in funky
conditions
maybe you have seen in the last episode
the part with tim and precious plastic
version 4. i was also one of the chefs
in that project and cooked there for
seven months for 30 to 60 people so yeah
i would say i have some experience with
community cooking i usually cook vegan
because i used to eat vegan by myself
and more or less mostly into working for
projects who try to push a healthy and
sustainable diet so let me just show you
how preparing a typical meal here in
project camp looks like
[Music]
so today
we're gonna eat the red lentil curry
and
leftover rice balls from the rice we
didn't eat yesterday it's coated with
pumpkin seed flour i made
and we're gonna also eat
snap peas with soy and lemon
and a kale salad with tahini and maybe
some strawberries from our garden if we
have
ripe ones
and
if it's not too much probably it is then
we're gonna eat some parsnips with honey
and garlic grilled
good stuff
so welcome to the project count kitchen
i'm gonna give you a short tour
come on in
here right on the
left
we are having our nuts and seeds shelf
which we usually
like with everything which is dry
ingredient we are buying it in
big amounts in bulks in the organic
market in the next town
and
it's also true for all our
dry ingredients like buckwheat all kinds
of kinds of beans and
[Music]
rice
lentils
sesame seeds flax seeds we are buying
them in five kilo packages
um here we have all the bread we are
eating is usually self-baked we are
heating our firewood oven up in every
week once on friday
next stop is
our fridge
i'm gonna let you peek into it
we have a full system all the leftovers
are here in glass containers
um
here's all the jar food we use
mustards pickles
this is a funky kind of bean also all
the fruits we are eating
ooh cookies
and the beer
um here we have our breakfast box oat
milk we are making it out of oats a
bunch of hummus
garlic i should use this
green stuff we have um
every week on tuesdays we are getting a
box from our neighbors saran nunu who
are organic farmers here we are getting
um
a big box with their veggies leafy
greens a lot of carrots
spinach
cabbages
and all the fresh food is always on the
bottom
and from that up we are using first what
is the oldest
and
next up we have our
spices here
they are always also buying them
in bigger amounts biggest
possible amounts
here
we have our jar
drawer
with all the popcorn coconut oil honey
oat flour
peanut butter
flax seed powder everything which comes
in the jars
and all the
big refill bags for the dry goods on the
shelves
we have a bunch of jars here
pots
four spoons
and knives
and
the interesting part is also our oven
which is not working as an oven
but we are storing our
veggies which don't need refrigerating
here like all the potatoes sweet
potatoes onions pumpkins garlic
and on the bottom it's a huge amount of
potatoes from our really good really
sweet neighbor fernanda
who's giving us a lot of
veggies all the time not just potatoes
we got a huge amount of snap peas from
her this week
for dinner
okay that's it
[Music]
so
[Music]
excuse me that these are snap things so
maybe that's the american word
[Music]
um
[Music]
so these are from the rice from
yesterday
mushroom rice and just plain white rice
and i mixed it with the potato dish we
it for lunch yesterday and it got such a
smooth and awesome texture
and i just coated it with
pumpkin seeds like a flour from pumpkin
seeds
i think it's gonna taste good yeah good
freestyle dish it is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let's eat
[Music]
ready
[Music]
[Music]
having some
nice thing about having your own
so today it's a special event
as you might know we have a lot of water
on the land and now we go a level up on
the upgrade of the land we were gifted
by our great neighbors
a
path to a waterfall so we right now
stand on neighbor's land
but
they decided to open a path so we could
bath in the waterfall now that hot days
are coming so
let's see what's happening around here
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
let me actually show you where the
waterfall is exactly like i said the
place is located in our neighbor to
neckasland
from the camp it's an easy walk of five
minutes and as you can see it in this
shot our base camp is right here
you follow this public road which is
just next to the camp and then walk down
this path across to nyquist property and
finally you find this beautiful place
located right here
and now it's time to clean it
as you can surely imagine it it is how
it always is a huge amount of nasty
brumbles spiky thorns and all kind of
painful plants are just waiting for us
they open all of this path and now we
just decided to clean it a bit better so
we can easier access to the waterfall
without getting spiky bushes stuck in
our head or anything
and we started
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
yo
watch out for the grumbles
so one of the cool things of us clearing
up this place is that it's not just cool
for us but it's also cool for the native
trees that are around here
i sit under a willow tree and we just
created some space for a fig tree
chestnut tree
oak trees elderflower trees so in the
future they will be able to grow a bit
larger and just give shade to this space
in the instead of this space being
shaded by brambles
[Applause]
so the waterfall is now cleaned
after a lot of brumbles and a lot of
thorns
we have easy access to the waterfall
and the cool thing is that with removing
a lot of dead trees and bushes now the
place is much more fire resilient
and that's an important thing here on
the land
for now you guys can watch the interview
that i spoke about tunicas and his
relationship to this place and now this
place came to be what it is today and i
hope you enjoy what he says because he's
a special guy
foreign
foreign
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
is
foreign
right thanks for watching this was it
for this episode but for the next
episode we will have a video about our
current challenges and we will also have
a q a so if you guys have any questions
for us in the team just post them down
below and we'll try to answer them
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video
so thanks for watching and see you in
the next video
thanks for watching and see you in the
next video
was good
it was good
so
thanks and see you in the next episode
[Music]
you